hey there guys these are staircase Pike
push-ups not sure if I invented them let
me know if you've seen this anywhere
before but it's something I've been
doing lately so Pike push-ups as you're
probably aware are like push-ups but at
a more steep incline and what this
allows you to do is to Target the
shoulders more and it's great for
building up to things like handstand
push-ups problem is that Pike push-ups
on the ground don't offer a massive
challenge for a lot of people and
raising your feet up onto something
isn't always that practical especially
if you lack a little bit of mobility in
your hamstrings for example so doing
them on the stairs is a great way to
overcome some of these issues it's a bit
more horizontal than a real Pike push-up
but I still think it's plenty steep
enough at the same time what this allows
you to do is to go past the ground where
the ground would be getting into a much
deeper position and challenging those
shoulders and pecs a little bit more a
tip is to do this on the bottom steps so
that if you do fall off you're not going
to injure yourself